[Musique]
bon soit la réunion bonjour le monde
entier mais dites moi comment il est si
ça plait bien moins et mieux
bienvenue dans les pas sorti de
l'auberge l'émission qui déchire tout
alors où est ce qu'on est au jeu du
moment
aujourd'hui nous les dans les
hauts-de-seine musc vers la rivière
jusqu'en l'aide l'église les connaît
alors on est chez un de ceux qui va nous
présenter ces cabanes alors marc m'a
aidé jolie cabane d'un fonds de ravine
avec les jo ou deux parties bref c'est
une magnifique on nous ferme aussi
ont-ils eu à manger 1 et connaît un
moment donné devant titres iphone 1 donc
on aura quoi on aura je crois du coup
les cocos et une spécialité ch'tis
laurent m'a dit que c'était une issue
après il on va voir bon voire tout
simplement
regardez moi cette belle vue l'émission
commence bien et vous allez me suivre
tout varsovie au guichet à l'égard
un ami
[Musique]
m
là
une aubaine
locaux
côté saveurs sucrées mois déjà merci de
nous et tu viens avec nous
est ce que tu peux nous est un petit peu
ou est ce qu'on est
et qu'est ce qui se passe sur ces
domaines parce que la scea domaine marin
ne la fais ça va jusque là dedans le
fond là bas c'est impressionnant du
baume sait comment ça se passe quand
même sur une île on a des cabanes en
chambres d'hôtes ont fait table d'hôte
aussi week end et ont mal agi la chanson
pouvoir s'aguerrir sur un autre ami
deux rats ligne
luxuriance alors cabane ravine
luxuriante à manger que demande le
peuple
[Musique]
la rallye on l'a eu en friche
complètement en friche
elle n'avait pas été visitée depuis
plusieurs années et on a décidé à
composer avec son aspect naturel tout en
lui donnant un
un aspect pratiquants qui veut dire en
fait que là le petit sentier on va
continuer de descendre tout ça s'était
aménagé par vous-même et oui les régions
d'oignies pour l'exemple des hommes
[Musique]
sellal organique est juste ici des
avocatiers un peu parcours d'élu 6
partout partout des manguiers départ à
yale
[Musique]
alors tu prends ça je me dope au pilot
tu écrases avec le piment le chien et la
boîte en guyane
m
[Musique]
ali
ce temps
[Musique]
alors on à la ligne chikhi et dans un
ordre politique on à la can
on n'a pas que de laquelle sur le côté
on a la bamboo qui est juste face à
abreuver et on a la passion parce qu on
a une ligne de passion sur l'art barbe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec l'équipe on a eu dernièrement
on entend le bruit de la cascade qui
coule
de nos pas vers des bassins ya un bassin
alors après forcément ça reste quelque
chose de naturel mais oui il ya un
bassin casque allez une petite plage
pour les petites général et est ce que
tu veux que je t'emmène dans ma cuisine
découvrir une faille chez moi je
m'arrache les mots de la bouche mais tu
lis dans mes pensées ma chère parce que
ce sinistre est chez nous on a quelque
chose qui arrache pas comme le piment
mais qui rage et tu vois que tu es monté
tout ça la cité celle ci bas je veux
être sage qu'on ne la vois tu veux y
aller maintenant parfois tu m'as dit
tabataba fin si tu as faim et envie de
manger une petite mamie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est maintenant le cuisiner alex c'est
le moment de cuisine et tu sais quoi
après après tout ces sentiers ses
explications sur les arbres et les
mangues et nana j'avoue j'ai un petit
peu faim bonjour monsieur je me présente
oui c'est bernard non mon primeur et mon
producteur de fruits et légumes
il vend à la rivière il à son chant pas
très loin là et c'est grâce à lui que
j'arrive à bien nourrir mes autres le
matin et le soir parfait mais écoute moi
je te propose de on va attaquer tout ça
chose promise chose due à l'ex voilà mon
fond de tarte
voilà mon pare balles voilà ma crème
fraîche à lomé il faudra que tu
m'explique pas ce que je sais pas trop
où on met quoi avant la crème fraîche ou
le maroilles tu mets du coupé en
tranches comme ça assez fine et après on
place plus ou moins régulièrement
[Musique]
maintenant je mets l'accent très mal a
su combler trop cédé n'a aucunement ça
fera du tout pas du tout non loi que
vous faites ça peut très bien encore
problème là vous voulez c'est ok allez
hop ou sarah ah oui ben ali baddou a
occupé la prochaine super nord à l'est
voilà comme ça c'est bon pour toi
impeccable vaquera gaspiller la dernière
calorique
[Musique]
c'est l'odeur qui va nous arriver que
ces quartiers
il a pu imaginer
[Musique]
julien super
moi ce que j'aime bien là c'est que je
reconnais un peu tout ce que moi j'ai
dans ma cuisine les épices les brèdes
etc
mais il ya quand même des petits
mélanger une petite façon de faire que
j'aime bien en fait je cuisine comme
pour moi je cuisine avec mon coeur j'ai
pas de savoir faire j'ai pas
d'apprentissage propre mais je me dis
voilà qu'est ce que j'aimerais manger
moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup les brèdes
mais j'ai tendance à croire que ça me
manque un peu de matière du coup
rajouter les chouchous ça permet de
densifier ce côté un peu mou de la brède
après le mélange des carottes cause
c'est à prouver avec le poulet qui a été
marine et c'est assez logique aussi j'ai
un combat énorme qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure
finalement j'ai l'impression que je fais
me cuisine au bon sens et comme pour moi
c'est beau c'est beau jeu rien à dire
ces gosses coutume c'est qu'ils
connaissent un le rap ça me connaît bien
lupa marois et maroilles alors là on va
charger le bentô je les fais safrané
avec un peu de combat va aussi ça le
rappel de la sauce je vais mettre les
brèdes et les chouchous
[Musique]
du coup les voilà le panier d'alex est
servi et je vais conduire le panier dans
la cuisine extérieure pour alex
[Musique]
alex le romain est servi c'est l'heure
du repas alors je te dépose sa là tu vas
pouvoir découvrir ce qu'on a cuisiné
sous forme de benneteau c'est quand tous
les clients en fait c'est comme ça c'est
ça comme une petite dînette d'accord tu
emmènes le repas ici oui et puis on les
arrivées et partent avec mon niveau
c'est ça et foulards dînette beaucoup
sur ma terrasse
m
on a mis
[Musique]
olivier nous rejoindre
olivier le compagnon le mari
mari d'anne sophie comment cette idée de
créer cet endroit est d'accueillir des
gens parce que c'est un métier quand
même c'est un métier noble moi j'aime
j'aime bien ça comment comment tout ça
c'est arrivé dans votre dans votre tête
dans votre vie en fait je suis venu mois
chez à 23 ans la jeune 23 ans donc il ya
quatre ans il ya une quinzaine d'années
jeux jeux gbe mon pied à la réunion et
quand je suis sorti de l'avion j'ai su
que c'était ici ma place ont fêté hier
jour on s'est réveillé un matin disant
ah les changements en changeant de vie
et puis bah ça s'est imposée tellement
facilement à moi en fait c'était
tellement la réunion qui me rappelait
systématiquement à chaque pub à la
réunion je pleurais quand je mangeais
quelque chose qui ressemblait vaguement
un truc réunionnais je pleurais donc
revenir s'installer ici il ya cinq ans à
la naissance du deuxième enfant ça s'est
imposée tellement naturellement après
quoi faire ça a été aussi assez rapide
en fait on s'est aperçu que le concept
des cabanes du logement insolite c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui n'existait
pas à la réunion
et alors c'est vrai qu'on a une
clientèle extérieure mais alors je pense
que de notre plus belle clientèle c'est
la clientèle réunionnaise parce qu'on
fait découvrir des choses nous en tant
que oreilles à des réunionnais et c'est
vraiment un plaisir de partager ça en
fait on est dans les changes tout le
temps on reçoit au trombone et je te
parle pas des changes monétaires je
parle des songes humain qu'est ce que tu
conseilles aujourd'hui pour aller voir
dans les parages
allez voir la cascade aller voir
l'église du rosaire aller faire la
marche des canaux la marche des tapages
aller voir le point de vue la forêt
cryptomérias on est tout à quelques
minutes en voiture en fait et avec un
peu de sueur et d'huile de genoux il ça
vaut vraiment le coup je vous dis au
revoir olivier et anne-sophie à la
prochaine président e par jour
je pars
vite je pars 800 te retourner au revoir
[Musique]
et l'émission se termine devant l'église
du rosaire à l'arrivée à saint louis
un bâtiment de 1937 superbe bâtiment
pour regarder comme de bons sentiments
now tour je vous dis tout simplement
aurevoir à la prochaine et on n'est
vraiment pas sorti de l'auberge
c'est moi qui te le dis parce que
regarde là mon ventre les places la
pente
[Musique]